ازمات سياسيه واقتصاديه خانقا بعيشها
السودان بالفتره الاخيره لكن الجديد انه
شرطه مكافحه المخدرات بالسودان ما بيمر
اليوم بدون ما تعلن عن ضبط شحنه مخدرات في
العاصمه او في الولايات لدرجه انه الموضوع
وصل انه يتحول لاخبار يوميه على منصات
الاعلام الرسميه وبعدين انتشار المخدرات
بشكل كبير اطلق مستخدمون مواقع التواصل
بالسودان هاشتاج الحق ولدك لمحاربه تفشل
المخدرات بالسودان بسرعه عامه وما يعرف
خصوصا بمخدر الايس كريستال الفتاه واللي
بيعرف كمان بمخدر الشيطان على وجه الخصوص
طبعا عن هذه الحمله يوم مدام انتشار
المخدرات في السودان بتنضم لنا من الخرطوم
الدكتوره منى علي المستشاره في علاج
الادمان اهلا بك يا دكتوره منى معانا
دكتوره منى بدايه خلينا نحكي عن انتشار
هاي في السودان بالفعل ما مدى انتشارها
وتغلغل لها من بين الشباب لغايه لدرجه انه
يتم اطلاق هذا الوسم والهاش تاج ولدك
طيب اهلا وسهلا مساء النور معكم في قناه
العربيه المستشاره المستشاره لبنى علي
محمد عبد الرحمن خبير استراتيجي في علاج
الادمان مدير مركز غادرين لعلاج الادمان
عدد التاهيل الحقيقه
ان شاء الله طيب بالنسبه الكريستال عايز
حقيقي انتشر انتشار كبير جدا يمكن معروف
عالميا اي دوله في العالم يكون فيها مشاكل
بتاعت عدم استقرار امني ونزاعات وتظاهرات
موجوده في الدوله بالاضافه لان الخرطوم او
السودان بصوره عامه دوله متراميه الاطراف
يعني عندنا حدود مفتوحه في ثمانيه دول
الانتشار الايسبح كميه كبيره جدا على
مستوى الولايات الخرطوم والولايات يمكن
الولايات الحدوديه كولايات كسلا احنا حسي
جايين قبل اقل من 20 يوم كميات كبيره جدا
دخلت الولايه ويمكن للسهوله الحصول عليها
اصبح الانتشار كثيف يعني الجرام بتاع
الايسونات كسره باربعه الف جنيه في ولايه
الخرطوم ب18
الالحق ولدك هي الحمد لله
ومدى خطورته لانه في يعني مخدرات انواع
كثيره مدى خطوره هذا تحديدا
طيب يوجد في السودان مخدرات كثيره من
ضمنها اللي هو البانجو او الحشيش اللي
بيزرع في محميه الردوم ولكن الخطوره
والفرق بين المخدرات والمخدرات الثانيه
الايس من اول جرعه ممكن الانسان يدمن اللي
هو عباره عن انفتامينات مرض الانفتامينات
منها الكبتاجون اكحبوب معروفه للناس
يستخدم ايس عالميا منذ الحرب العالميه اول
دولتين استخدموه هي المانيا واليابان
للجنود عشان يسهروا مسافات طويله وكده لكن
دخل السودان بكميات كبيره من بعد الثوره
كان السودان زمان سابقا هو معبر للمخدرات
ايا كان الانواع بتاعته لكن ما حصل الان
في يوم من الايام من ان احنا متابعين اكثر
من غرفه عمليات شهر مصعب منظمتنا ما حصل
يوم خطط الاخبار انه تم عبد غبيه معينه
سواء كانت الكريستال او الكبتاجون او او
البانجو او غيره انتشر ليه
كميه كبيره ولين نفسي اطلع اولا في اسباب
تعود للدوله في اسباب تعود للشباب
اللازوال بتعود للدوله البلد الوضع
السياسي غير مستمر الحدود المفتوحه
التحديات داخل السودان من النزاعات
والحروب كبيره جدا اكبر من الفتره اللي
فاتت همم بالنسبه للشباب العطاء العاليه
جدا جدا في احباط عن جدا وسط الشباب نحن
الان قاعدين في السيديو على البطاله
الاحباط السياسي خلينا نحددها يعني
الاحباط السياسي الان الناس قاعده في
الاستديو الان والمظاهرات بره وهم دول
الشباب اللي هما وعود الثوره
الشتاني الفتره بتاعه الكرونه خلت العطاله
الزمنيه الطويله خلت الاسباب املس يعني ما
في هدف واضح في الحياه عشان يقدروا يعني
يغطوا الفتره بيتقرون عالميا الرذيذ السنه
اللي حصل في زمن الكرونه ليس السودان فقط
كل الدول
الشده ثاني خلى المشاكل الامنيه الموجوده
لانتشار بقى عالي خالص خالص او
فيتامينات اللي صنع انت قلتي الخطوره
الخطوره لانه ممكن يصنع في اي مطبخ
سهل التصنيع طيب دكتوره بالنسبه للحمله
والهاشتاج الحق ولدك واضح بانها يعني نوعا
ما موجهه للاهلي عشان يقدرون خط الدفاع
الاول يعني بالنسبه لابنائهم هن اللي
يراقبوهم وهن اللي يساعدوهم للتخلص من هذه
القفه حطينا اكثر عن هذه النقطه وعن يعني
كيف شو هي فعاليات هاي الحمله وكيف عم
تنشر الوعي
طيب اولا احنا عابرين مؤسستنا بيتنا
بيشتغلنا لثلاثه سنوات في رفع التوعيه
اللي نزلت الوصمه الاجتماعيه زمان بنتكلم
عن انه كيف تودي ولدك المصحه عشان يتعالج
الان الحق ولدك مشكله لانه الكريستال عايز
اصبح الان وسط كله 10 متعاطين ماده
الكريستال ايس اصبح يصاب 4 منهم بمرض
الكبد الوبائي وصدق
العلاقه انه العلاقه انه اصلا الحقنه اللي
بتطعن وبها متوفره زي شير زميل مشاركه
ما هي بتوزع الحقن المحقونه بالطريقه ديت
دي الخطوره الحادثه خلت تخافش الثاني
الخرطوم ولا السودان بسرعه احنا ما جاهزين
اللي مراكز علاج بالكميه الكبيره لانه ال-
ال- العرض كثير او الطلب كثير على
المحاضره يمكن توجد ثلاثه مصحات حكوميه
الحمله الغرض منها توعيه الاهالي لانه يا
اخواننا اذا الاسره ما بقتيها صمام الامان
ما نقدر نعمل حاجه اكيد شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتوره لبنى علي المستشاره في علاج
الادمان كانت معنا من الخرطوم شكرا
[موسيقى]